as rioters continue to plague democratic
cities across the country the media
blamed trump
and conservatives the covid wars grow
even stupider and a gap develops between
biden and the bernie bros i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show the
ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why haven't you gotten a vpn
yet visit expressvpn.com
ben alright so remember that time when
the media kept telling us over and over
and over that the pride
the protests were mostly peaceful mostly
peaceful protesting
remember that that was good times wasn't
it that was fun i got there there's that
abc news headline one of the best
headlines ever over the past 48 hours
quote
protesters in california set fire to a
courthouse damaged a police station and
assaulted officers
after a peaceful demonstration
intensified not kidding that was the
actual headline from
the peace intensified intensified see
normally when peacefulness intensifies
then people get more peaceful but
apparently when peacefulness intensifies
according to abc news
that's when you set fire to a courthouse
damage a police station and assault
police officers but it's mostly peaceful
guys we keep hearing mostly peaceful
mostly peaceful mostly peaceful
and there's a stark divide between the
protesters and the rioters and the
looters
now i'm willing to hear that stark
divide obviously if you're rioting and
you're looting you're doing something
criminal if you're protesting
then you're not that is the stark divide
for me there is however a problem and
that is that the media sympathize with
the rioters and the looters
and as it turns out so do many members
of the protest movement
according to the new york times today
and remember we were told the protesters
were super peaceful
they had no intent on doing violence
they didn't even have sympathy for
violence right they were against the
violence they recognized that violence
was a bad idea
well not so much now some of you knew
this
my friend amy horowitz he's reported
from on the ground at these riots
and at the protests and he said he
couldn't find anybody who actually
condemned the rioting and the looting
from the protest so the sort of stark
divide at least
ideologically not in terms of behavior
but ideologically between the protesters
and the rioters and looters
basically has not existed since the
early days of the
blm protests which have now morphed into
antifa
protests well according to the new york
times they're now confirming what ami
reported
on my radio show they say peaceful
protesters with quote
room for rage sympathize with aggressive
tactics
minutes before midnight on sunday the
first firework of the evening screeched
low over the heads of protesters
gathered in portland oregon
sprinkling them with white flecks of
light and ricocheting into the
courthouse that has become a symbol of
an unwelcome federal incursion into a
local outcry over police brutality
now i love first of all how the new york
times immediately
posits that the only reason they're
attacking the courthouse is because of
the federal incursion
now that completely reverses the
timeline remember the feds did not
arrive until they attacked the
courthouse but the way the new york
times reports this if you were an alien
from outer space and you arrived and you
read just that paragraph you would
assume
that the feds arrived and then the
attacks began
the new york times says some ducked
under makeshift shields to protect
themselves from the falling sparks while
others cheered at the site of the
blazing projectile hurtling
toward the courthouse and the federal
law enforcement agents inside this
is what democracy looks like okay that's
not what democracy
looks like typically speaking when you
think of democracy you don't think of
people
firing projectiles of law enforcement
agents that one it isn't high on the
list
of democratic activities is to actually
engage in
anti-civilization violence typically
that's not
high on the list of of democratic agenda
items
in recent weeks says the new york times
protesters in portland have pointed
laser beams lobbed water bottles and
trash bags and in one case according to
the portland police bureau hurled an
open pocket knife at the officers
guarding the courthouse
they've used power tools crowbars and
bolt cutters to yank down a fence
in seattle demonstrators over the
weekend set fire to several construction
trailers at a youth detention facility
protests in richmond virginia l.a and
oakland were also marked by fires
yet the nightly assault on the federal
courthouse has been part of a much wider
peaceful resistance ah
so much peace peacefulness intensifying
across the nation
and i'm just going to point out here if
there had been one firework
shot at police officers during the tea
party movement
that would be the end of the world they
were called terrorists by members of the
obama administration as it was
they were called the tea party
terrorists by members of the obama
administration and members of the media
if the anti-lockdown protesters had so
much as sneezed
at the at the officers who were trying
to stop them
from breaking the law that would have
been an assault they would have been
charged right i mean
the media would have said that the
anti-lockdown protesters were the worst
people in the world
they did by the way anyway without them
actually overtly breaking the law here
you have people overtly breaking the law
but don't worry this is part of a much
wider peaceful resistance high school
students military veterans off-duty
lawyers
lines of mothers who call themselves the
wall of moms that began assembling
nearly two months ago in the wake of
george floyd's death at the hands of
minneapolis police
the aim as it has been in other cities
was to assemble for sweeping police
reform and racial justice no that's not
the aim
the aim is frankly for a lot of these
people it's a good time
seriously you can you cannot watch
footage of these protests and not come
away with the conclusion these are not
people attempting to actually effectuate
change these are folks who are having a
good time we're in the middle of a
lockdown
we've basically been told that you can't
do anything you can't go to church
not that a lot of these folks are going
to church you can't go out to a bar
you can't go to a concert in fact
there's a concert in new york last night
and andrew cuomo was very angry at the
concert
sadly no one thought to bring a black
lives matter t-shirt or it all would've
been fine
the only thing you are allowed to do in
today's society in public
with others is overtly resist law
enforcement and or have dance parties
in the thousands in the middle of the
street so this is basically becoming the
outlet
for a bored and angry country for a lot
of people
and that doesn't mean everybody isn't
genuine it does mean that a lot of
people who are not genuine
i'm not going to pretend that i think
that everybody who is firing projectiles
and police officers is looking for quote
unquote systemic change
as opposed to just being a jerk having a
good time at two o'clock in the morning
the raucous escalation in recent days
brought about by the deployment of
federal law enforcement officers and the
harsh tactics they have used against
protesters has prompted new debates
among the protesters over their own
tactics and goals
now battling nightly rounds of pepper
spray and impact munitions fired by
federal forces
some activists worry that the nightly
clashes are distracting from their
demands for defunding or reforming local
police departments
yeah you think it turns out that when
you fire crap at police officers people
are less sympathetic
to the perspective that we don't need
police officers
to see people standing in portland
destroying property was not actually
doing the work of advocating for black
people
was disturbing said rachel dixon the
vice president of noma county democrats
organizer in the black community
i think they're a distraction from the
everyday needs of people of color
especially black people
my life is not going to improve because
you broke the glass at the louis vuitton
store
well that of course is true but there's
only one problem
a huge percentage according to this
article of people who are engaged in the
protest actually have
a lot of sympathy for the people who are
engaging in more
aggressive tactics apparently
there are a lot of people who are who
are kind of happy with this i mean
that's the headline of the piece
kat brooks racial justice organizer in
oakland i don't know how you even apply
for that job
and the co-founder of the anti-police
terror project said black lives matter
protests and the movement to house
federal forces from cities where one
connected at struggle the debate among
organizers she said is the tactics that
protesters should use
her own view is that protesters cannot
be blamed for forcefully responding when
confronted with rubber bullets and
pepper spray as they happen in portland
i don't consider property destruction
violence she said violence is when you
attack a person or another living
breathing creature on this planet
windows don't cry and they can't die
okay first of all the idea
that property damage does not amount to
a form of violence is insane okay it's
patently insane if i come to your house
and i burn it down i have done an act of
violence against you
i have and if you don't believe me then
i'll come to your house and i'll burn it
down i mean like this is crazy
if somebody went to this lady's
apartment and just broke in and trashed
the place which was like you know what
this wasn't an act of violence i mean no
one was hurt after all this is all fine
it's all fine
not a big deal advocating for systemic
change
organizers in oakland which has a long
tradition of lab protests are watching
closely whether federal forces will be
deployed there
if the feds come to oakland it's going
to make portland look like disneyland
she said miss brooks she rejected the
notion put forward by mayor libby chef
of oakland that violence and property
destruction
reinforced trump's message that
anarchists were taking over the
country's streets
she says we could sit there and sing
kumbaya and suck lollipops between now
and november but if donald trump thinks
it makes sense to hit oakland and
detroit and some of the other
cities with large black populations then
that's what donald trump is going to do
so a lot of sympathy among the
protesters for people who are engaging
in violence and it's important to
recognize this because that is what
federal law enforcement and local law
enforcement are actually facing down
they're not facing down protesters these
protests have been going on for months
it did not escalate to people firing
pepper balls at people unless the people
who were having the pepper balls fired
at them
were engaged in violation of law we'll
get some more of this
in just one second first let's talk
about
having good clothes now i know you
probably have a lot of clothes in that
dresser right now
i know you you just picked up that that
kind of random t-shirt at that
family event and you're still wearing
that around and you look terrible let's
be frank about this what you need
is a great piece of clothing this is why
you need cut clothing
cuts has completely changed the game
their t-shirt has enough quality and
style to wear in the office or a date or
anywhere in between
you don't have to choose between a
classic look and a modern feel in 2016
steven borelli was struggling to find
the perfect t-shirt he wanted something
that had enough quality to be worn
professionally at work
yet also enough style for a night out no
matter where he looked nothing fit the
bill so he took matters into his own
hands
the result was a product you could be
proud to wear anytime anywhere without
sacrificing comfort i know because i
wear cut t-shirts
all the time they are supremely
comfortable and they look fantastic fit
fabric and function it's the only shirt
worth wearing athletic tailored looking
fit
it's perfect for work a date everything
in between it's pre-shrunk wrinkle-free
retains its shape
over time they're custom engineered
peek-a-pro fabric can only be described
as buttery so it really is soft i mean
it is soft on the skin
it is really comfortable and it looks
fantastic that's why cuts is the only
shirt worth wearing it is loved by your
favorite athletes entrepreneurs even
podcast hosts
like moi it seems like everyone is
wearing cuts these days get 15
off your first order by going to
cutclothing.com
shapiro that's cut c-u-t-s clothing dot
com
shapiro for 15 off the only shirt worth
wearing cutsclothing.com
shapiro okay so more federal agents have
been dispatched to portland
as protests are increasing according to
the washington post the trump
administration
is sending more federal agents to
portland the us marshal service decided
last week to send more deputies
according to an internal email reviewed
by the washington post
with personnel beginning to arrive last
thursday night the department of
homeland security is also considering a
plan to send an additional
50 u.s customs and border protection
personnel to the city
according to a senior administration
official involved in the federal
response
this would mark a significant expansion
of the federal force operating at the
portland
federal courthouse there were 114 agents
there in mid-july it's unclear how many
existing personnel could be sent home
after the arrival of 100 reinforcements
this by anybody treating this as
completely out of bounds is just
ignoring the realities on the ground but
that's exactly
what is happening one u.s attorney for
oregon is ripping portland officials
over the handling of the riots
u.s attorney billy williams he urged
portland residents to demand action from
local officials he's saying listen the
only reason the feds are even here
is because the local officials refuse to
do anything about this which suggests
that they have some sympathy for the
violence because they think the violence
is going to
actually effectuate change
from my standpoint it's it's nonsensical
it's just political theater um
it's unfortunate because everything law
enforcement
accomplishes to address
multiple fronts is done through
partnerships
to pass the resolution that you're
barred from talking with law enforcement
partners is
it's just political and that's
just so unfortunate short-sighted it's
it's um it doesn't help anything
um but you know it is what it is
that of course is absolutely right but
what you're seeing from local officials
is open
admiration for people who are engaged in
violence seattle mayor jenny durkin
who's just
awful i mean she's just an awful mayor
she allowed city blocks of her own city
to be ripped away from law and order and
dominated
by people who really can be described as
terrorists i mean if you take over a
two-block area
of downtown and then their shootings
that take place they're in and the first
responders are not allowed to come in
i don't know what else to describe that
as i mean that's insurrection okay the
seattle mayor however says that
by president trump deploying federal law
enforcement to protect federal property
it's a dry run for martial law now if
you're suggesting it's a dry run for
martial law what you really are
suggesting is that
violent uprisings against a dry run from
martial law are justified
how else do you read that right this is
just justification for violence by the
seattle mayor who has tolerated violence
in her own city and has tolerated the
degradation
of her own law and order in her own city
here's mayor jenny durkin just a trash
heap of a mayor
every time this president promises to
sow division he's successful at it
and he has he's clearly targeted cities
run by democratic mayors he said so
himself
he's using law enforcement as a
political tool
i hate to say it aaron but i really
believe that we are seeing the dry run
for martial law
this is a president that is using law
enforcement and federal forces for
political purposes
and that should be chilling to every
american it's a dry run for martial law
she's absolutely suggesting that the
president of the united states is going
to use federal force
to overwhelm all resistance to his own
agenda that's what she's suggesting
martial law by the way these are the
same folks who that president trump
should put down a national mass mandate
enforceable by federal law enforcement
it's very funny to watch all the same
people who claim that trump is a fascist
asking him to be a fascist it's really
exciting
but that's pretty crazy stuff and that
is the mayor of a major democratic city
which suggests again if you are
resisting a dry run for martial law this
makes you the good guys
if you're burning property and burning
starbucks and all this this makes you
the best this makes you actually
positive it's a good thing
we'll get to more of this in just a
second because the media some of the
media are just cheering this on
you can tell by their guest election
wait until you see one guest on msnbc
making some pretty wild claims about why
this violence is happening
in major cities we'll get to that in a
moment first let's talk about the fact
that there's an enormous amount of
censorship that goes on on social media
sites like an enormous amount they have
an enormous amount of control
over what you can see and what you can
hear today as we're going to talk about
in a little while
they actually banned donald trump jr
from twitter for the great crime of
tweeting out a video on
hydroxychloroquine
that most medical experts think is wrong
and they really can control
your informational flow well you can
help stop that by disguising
your ip address hiding your ip address
this is where expressvpn
comes in first of all all of these
social media sites the way they make
money is by gathering data on you and
then selling it to third party vendors
you don't need to give them your data
when you use expressvpn you anonymize
much of your online presence by hiding
your ip address that makes your activity
more difficult to trace and sell to
advertisers
expressvpn couldn't be easier to set up
you just tap one button on your phone or
computer and you are now protected
expressvpn also encrypts 100 of your
data to protect you from hackers and
internet bad guys
it's time to say no to censorship and to
shortening the ability to actually see
what you want to see
take back your online privacy at
expressvpn.com by visiting my special
link you get an extra three months of
expressive vpn service for free
again that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
expressvpn.com
to protect your data today they're great
and i'll make sure that you are
protected from hackers from
social media from all like
expressvpn.com get an extra three months
of expressvpn
service for free okay so rahm emanuel
former chicago mayor
he's of course blaming the federal
government he's saying that the real
problem here is that people are
conflating the protesters
and the writers and looters except that
the writers and the looters are among
the protesters and the protesters many
of them
are expressing open sympathy for the
rioters and the looters and so are
members of the media
so there's this inside outside game
that's being played here by democrats
how dare you lump together these people
we're like okay i don't want to lump
together
those people and then the media's like
yeah but they're the same so why are you
ripping rioters and looters
the most the most beloved tactic these
days is the so-called mott and bailey
tactic of argumentation
where you make an extraordinarily
extreme claim somebody attacks the
extraordinarily extreme claim
and then you basically you basically
run away right you you go into retreat
up into an argument that is less
attackable so you see this with black
lives matter somebody says you know
black lives matter means defund the
police you're like
defunding the police is a terrible idea
it's gonna hurt black people they say
well you what i really meant is that
black lives matter you don't believe
black lives matter that's a mutton
bailey tactic
it's named after the old sort of
medieval fortresses where you'd have a
town
right that was the mott down at the
bottom of a hill
and then if that was attacked everybody
would retreat up the hill to the bailey
which was the
which was the central castle right this
is what you're seeing over and over
you're seeing this with regard to the
rioters and the looters as well
people will say the writers and the
looters right i mean they're just
they're justified because
i mean martial law is on the horizon
that's ridiculous that's ridiculous
i mean why are you justifying writing
and looting nook how dare you conflate
writing and looting with protesting i
didn't i never did that
here's rahm emanuel doing that routine
there are people trying to hijack these
legitimate protesters
and create violence and i think in the
response from the federal government
shouldn't be
trying to make antifa the face of the
protest
let the local law enforcement take the
lead if they need federal assistance to
last for it like we've done in every
other situation
going back and in this situation
understand the protesters who are asking
america
to live up to the promise of america and
know that others
individuals not a lot but are trying to
hijack these protests
for their own violent needs okay so
that is uh that's good stuff here also
good stuff an activist named erica i was
on msnbc featured on msnbc
you're your source for all left-wing
news and suggested openly
on this activist that what's actually
happening in major cities the violence
is rising not because the police are
absent violence is rising because the
federal government is shipping guns into
inner cities
in order to create violence this was
featured on msnbc
in a segment called america in crisis
racial injustice protests across the u.s
spur police clashes again notice even in
that chiron the conflation
between protests and violence right
racial injustice protests
spur police clashes it's the police who
are responding to just normal protests
for racial injustice against racial
injustice
it's amazing stuff here's this activist
suggesting something absolutely nuts
to virtually no pushback by the msnbc
hosts
we see the influx of guns in communities
across the nation
once again people were in the house for
three months
they didn't lost their jobs lost their
family they was grieving
they don't have money to buy these guns
where are they coming from
and so just like in the 70s and 80s when
we saw the counter intelligence program
put guns and drugs into certain
communities
to create certain behaviors to stop the
rise
of protests and and movements we see it
again
okay this is absolutely bizarre nonsense
and there's no push back on msnbc so far
as i could tell
to any of this this is just an activist
right spouting activism
things are going really well in the
country it seems well i think that the
only way that the country can truly heal
is if hbo
has itself a really important
session like a really important uh an
important talk
so hbo has now finally given a voice to
left-wing voices hbo that notoriously
right-wing outlet
they finally opened up a space for
left-wingers to talk
hbo sports is now going to air seeing
america with megan
rapinoe on august 1st showing a
conversation between the u.s women's
soccer team captain
representative alexander ocasio-cortez
famous sports person 16-19 project
founder and pulitzer prize winner nicole
hannah jones and great fiction writer
also famous sports person and comedian
and television host hassan minhaj also
amazing amazing sports person so i'm so
glad that hbo sports is going to air a
conversation between megan rapinoe who's
most
mostly famous for complaining about how
america sucks while making millions of
dollars
complaining about how america sucks the
colin kaepernick of soccer over here
aoc who of course is is famous as a
sports commentator
nicole hannah jones who is famous for
just making up american history
and hassan minhaj who is a comedian and
tv host
peter nelson executive vice president of
hbo sports i quote we are grateful megan
rapinoe would choose hbo as home for
this conversation
and look forward to more opportunities
with her to continue this dialogue megan
is fearless in speaking out
on issues issues joined by
representative aoc nicole hannah jones
and hassan minhaj this conversation's
embrace this conversation embraces
the challenges we collectively face so
basically it is a bill maher panel
without belmar
is is what we are seeing right here in
the trailer
rapido says i'm a gay female athlete i
can't ever just be
one thing because she's an
intersectionality intersection now she
can never just well she can she can just
be a social justice warrior that's what
she is
hannah jones says she views the upcoming
election as quote the first election
where we are actually voting for
our lives okay god this person
nicole hannah jones is just the fact
that they've made her defacto editor of
the new york times this speaks the fact
that the new york times is a flaming
bag of human feces at this point it is
just
this is the first election where black
people are actually voting for their
lives truly
truly is it for for a pseudo-historian
she should know a little bit about
american history it seems like there
have been
a lot more risky times to be a black
person in america than 2020
the first election where we're actually
voting for our lives
rapido according to mediaite who led her
team to victory during the 2019 world
cup has consistently
dedicated herself to activism and human
rights issues
it's an honor to host a show where a
critical conversation between some of
america's most innovative thought
leaders
i'm so thankful to hbo for providing
such a powerful platform
so much powerful platforming for an
entire
i look forward to a conversation in
which one person says something that a
bunch of other people kneel
not along it'll be very very exciting
stuff
very exciting stuff it is interesting to
note how
liberals and uh have liberals have a
choice to make i've been talking about
this for
for a few weeks now liberals have a
choice to make in our culture
choice number one is they can fight back
against the radical left
and they can join forces with people in
the middle and they can recognize that
while they may agree with the radical
left on some policy prescriptions
they actually agree more with the middle
and maybe even some on the right about
the rights that we all have and how the
country
should basically be rooted in notions of
rights or they can cave to the radical
left
and you can see who's choosing which way
in hollywood everybody is moving to the
woke left very very quickly
octavia spencer the actress she now says
that
the only way that people should play
disabled people is if they are actually
disabled
so acting is out the window according to
octavia spence that's exciting stuff
here's octavia spencer yesterday
nothing can replace lived experience
and authentic representation
that's why it's imperative that we cast
the appropriate actor
for the appropriate role and that means
people with disabilities as well
asking abled-bodied actors in roles for
characters with disabilities
is offensive unjust
and deprives an entire community of
people from opportunities you know it's
true because there's a lot of piano
music in the background that's how you
always know these videos are true online
is when there's somebody in the
background who's playing intense
piano music it's real but the intense
piano music never has a left hand it's
really just the right hand up near the
upper register of the keys
you gotta love actresses coming out and
saying that acting is now wrong
so the woke left on the march also
you've seen how the aclu has turned
remember that time the aclu used to
defend
sort of the liberal notion of rights the
kkk
she did by the way play somebody with
with schizophrenia as my understanding
octavia spencer i don't think she
suffers from schizophrenia anyway
an aclu staff attorney was tweeting out
in the same
vein so aclu used to be kind of
traditionally liberal and the aclu was
an organization that said
we may not agree with what you say but
we definitely will defend your rights to
say it
well now they've decided nope we're
caving to the radical left
as well the culture wars really are not
happening on the right as much as they
are happening between
the left and the liberals it looks like
increasingly the liberals are losing but
what's happening there is that means
it's driving everybody in the center to
the right
now the question is whether trump could
take advantage of that electorally
that's another question we'll get to
that
in just one second first let's talk
about something fantastic you can do
for your kids during this pandemic i
mean the fact is that
if you have little kids at home you know
they are super bored right now and you
got to keep them entertained somehow but
instead of just popping on the tv and
letting the tv be the babysitter
why not get them educated why not read
them books and you're thinking but how
do i pick which books should come how do
i make that selection this is where
literati comes in this service is just
phenomenal i have a six-year-old i have
a four-year-old and i have a tiny little
baby and she's super cute
literati will do stuff for all of them
literati is the subscription
book club that makes it easy to find
unique thought-provoking books for your
kids by delivering great stories
straight to your doorstep
literati knows home deliveries are
critical for meeting your need for
uplifting educational tools in the
coming weeks
reading books together will help create
a time of adventure and bonding for your
family
and has real educational benefits kids
who read books have better vocabularies
and longer attention spans
each literary box contains five
beautiful books based on a theme
contains exclusive original art and a
personalized note
to your kid my daughter loves the books
that literati center my son too
like these are their favorite books that
we have in the house and we have
probably hundreds of books in the house
literati does an amazing job of
selecting really fascinating books
tailored to your kid you only keep your
favorites and you send the rest back for
free that means you're only paying for
the books your kids will love
with schools and libraries closed
literati is working to get books in the
hands of families you can reuse that
literary box and donate outcome books
literati will match every one you send
for a limited time go to literati.com
shapiro you get 25 off your first two
orders which is an awesome
deal honestly it's so it's such a great
service for your kids go check it out
right now
literati.com shapiro 25 off your first
two orders
l-i-t-e-r-a-t-i dot com slash repair
literati.com
shapiro go check them out right now okay
so
the the aclu has decided to embrace the
radical left as well there's a
aclu staff attorney named chase strangio
chastringio and chase strangio has
basically decided that the aclu's old
slogan of
say what you want if it falls inside the
first amendment we'll defend your right
to say it
they've moved from that to if you say
something we don't like it's now a
danger
a danger chase stranger staff attorney
for the aclu
says it would be nice to ignore the
harry potter harry potter person would
be jk rowling
but the rhetoric being used on her
massive platform is feeding a genocidal
impulse that already exists in
government and within individuals
she is dangerous situating the trans
subject and the trans body in the
contested discursive space
the way she does pulls the conversation
around transness into the posture of
working to locate
the legitimate trans subject okay that's
that's just gobbledygook that's not even
in english
the idea being that we must defend
against the allegation that too many
trans people in the world reflects a
problem that is after all her point
and in so doing we cede the conversation
to cis people and institutions
and perhaps most insidiously in doing so
we give the false impression that sexed
bodies
are things only trans people have by
obscuring the larger structural
impulses behind bodily policing and the
violence of the sex binary we ensure the
continuation of these structures ah the
violence of the sex binary guys
the fear that a trans person of any age
might actually love and embrace their
bodies what drives jk and others they
don't want to just make it harder for us
to survive
they want to destroy any joy we might
feel in our journeys
okay this is the aclu staff attorney now
saying the jk rowling is dangerous
and is pushing genocidal impulses by
pointing out that biological women exist
okay liberals are going to have to make
a choice do they wish to side with this
kind of nuttiness
or do they wish to acknowledge that
conversations should and can
take place and this is an open debate
because what we're seeing right now in
america's major cities is that liberals
are increasingly saying
okay if you want to do violence do
violence all right well and if anybody
says that violence is bad stop focusing
on the violence why are you even
focusing on the violence
well what this is driving rational
people to do is run headlong from the
radical left
like run screaming from the radical left
this is why you're seeing elon musk
increasingly tweet things that are
pissing off the radical left yesterday
he tweeted out a graphic said das
kapital in a nutshell
karl marx's book there's a picture of
karl marx
and said give me that for free hungry
santa
good for elon musk good for elon musk
man who's actually built a company as
opposed to all these people who just
want to steal other people's labor
but this is going to be the gap that
opens up you're starting to see it open
up a little bit
inside the democratic party as well and
this is the gap that joe biden is going
to have to bridge over so far
anti-trumpness has basically bridged
over the gap between radical left and
liberals who may not like the radical
left
very much it'll be interesting to see
whether that lasts
so yesterday the dnc platform committee
voted down medicare for all
as part of the platform they did it
overwhelmingly and people were very
angry in burning land
there was dennis mcdonough co-chair of
the biden campaign voting against
medicare for all as part of the platform
members voting on this voting has closed
on this amendment
the motion was not approved by the
members
and the language as proposed will remain
unchanged
there were 36 yes 125
now and three abstentions
that's on amendment 328 194.
okay so the burning people are super
duper pissed because the bernie people
are saying why don't you give us
everything we want and the biden people
are like because if we do that nobody
will like us
that is a battle that is gonna rage out
into the open and started to break out a
little bit yesterday
when a sanders campaign coacher named
nina turner ripped biden
she actually suggested there's a direct
quote it's like saying to somebody
about choosing between biden and trump
quote it's like saying to somebody you
have a bull of bleep in front of you and
all you've got to do is eat half of it
instead of the whole thing
it's still bleep bleep being the s-word
so
this is going to be a problem that does
eventually rip open the democratic party
the question is
whether trump can exploit it and this is
why trump needs to be
very focused in the way he campaigns and
i know that a lot of people out there
who just think all the polls are wrong
and that everything is hunky-dory let me
just tell you something people inside
the trump administration inside the
trump campaign they understand that the
polls aren't all fake they do
they get that trump is not in good shape
electorally right now
and they understand that trump has to be
a lot more focused in how he has
approached this campaign
so far there is a gap emerging in the
democratic party it is a gap between the
radical left
and the old school liberals but that's
been glossed over again by
anti-trumpness
you can see that gap starting to expose
itself with regards to the violence and
protests in the cities you can see it
starting to expose itself
in terms of the canceled culture where
members of the traditional
liberal left are looking at their
radical left compatriots and going you
guys are kind of fascist aren't you
okay that is a gap that a a professional
politician who's good at this could rip
wide open
that's what trump should be doing that
requires two things one
him to focus completely on ripping open
that scene
because it's very important for the
country that seem to be ripped open the
radical left needs to be excised they
need to be
anybody who claims that violence is a
solution to political problems
needs to be excised from the
conversation that does not mean
obviously not violence or anything i'm
explicitly denouncing violence
for those in media matters who don't
understand english when i say excise i
mean there is an overton window if you
are claiming
that attacks on federal law enforcement
are part of that overton window you're
doing it wrong
the liberals need to take back over the
democratic party and trump can help that
happen
and if the democratic party keeps caving
to the radical left maybe traditional
liberals might think
about moving away from a democratic
party that no longer represents them
i know a lot of traditional liberals who
are looking in horror at what's
happening
right now trump if he's skillful can
exploit that and he should exploit that
that requires two things focus and not
providing the democrats with a shiny
object
namely namely trump to gather around an
attack we're gonna get to that in a
second because that brings us to covet
policy we'll get to that momentarily
first
let's talk about the fact that it would
be wonderful if you never had to go to
the post office
again i mean the post office does a lot
of great stuff but do you really want to
go to the post office probably not i
mean you stand in line and then it takes
a while you got to show up your stuff
over there
and especially in kovadira it really is
not like a thing
so why not instead just do everything
from home
as we adjust to the new normal we need
to be smart about how we do business
luckily there's stamps.com to make
things easier
thousands of small business owners have
discovered the benefits of stamps.com in
recent months they've been able to keep
their businesses running and avoid the
crowds at the post office all from their
own computers with stamps.com you can
print postage on demand avoid going to
the post office
you'll save money with discounted rates
you can't even get at the post office
stamps.com offers ups services with
discounts up to 62 percent
and no residential surcharges here at
dailywire we've been using stamps.com
since 2017. we don't waste our time we
don't waste our money which is why we
are a profitable enterprise
stamps.com brings all the mailing and
shipping services you need directly to
your computer in the comfort
of your home or office whether you're a
small business sending invoices or an
online seller shipping out products
or you're just working from home and you
need to mail some stuff stamps.com can
handle it all with ease you use your
computer and you print official us
postage
24 7 any letter any any package any
class of mail anywhere you want to send
it and
giant discounts as well right now my
listeners get a special offer that
includes a four-week trial plus free
postage and digital scale
no long-term commitment just go to
stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage type in shapiro
that is stamps.com
enter shapiro and get that special offer
forward trial plus free postage and a
digital scale
no long-term commitment save yourself
and your business tons of money and time
stamps.com and use
that code shapiro alrighty so folks if
you haven't heard by now my new book how
to destroy america in three easy steps
it is officially on sale it has sold
i believe last count nearly a hundred
thousand copies in the first week we've
been seeing amazing enthusiasm from you
guys we are really excited about its
release we did a live signing last
tuesday
got to tell you we almost sold out so
i'm signing copies of my books today
and uh tomorrow before i get carpal
tunnel then it's over because i've
signed literally tens of thousands of
copies at this point so
get in your order right now because
otherwise it's just not gonna happen for
you go get your copy right now at
dailywire.com
ben the book covers the two
fundamentally different visions of
america that are now
being exposed in public view one vision
says america should hold together
because we have a common philosophy the
declaration of independence a common
culture a common history
the other says that america basically
sucks it was always based on a lie
the 1619 project robin d'angelo these
are disintegrationists okay that is the
battle of our time the book isn't just a
rebuttal it's a lot of those bad
disintegrationist arguments
it is the antidote to that you can give
it to your liberal friends and point out
to them you actually have a lot in
common with them and we should be able
to unify around a lot of these concepts
that is how the country gets saved how
to destroy america in three easy steps
you can go pick it up right now at
dailywire.com
ben and you can pick up a signed copy
because it's i'm not gonna keep signing
i mean it's just
that that's the deal meanwhile 2020 you
might have noticed
this year is crazy and the media are
just lying all the time which is why you
need all access to our reader's pass
at dailywear if you're a political
junkie get a reader's pass today from
dailywire.com you'll get access to
exclusive op-eds from us
your podcast hosts as well as guest
writers in-depth analysis from our daily
wire reporters on top
of our regular breaking news this
membership tier is already a bargain
it's three bucks a month if you join
today you get your first month for 99
cents you also get access to our mobile
app
and you receive push notifications for
breaking news and special content
and you can join the community of daily
ware members who are commenting and
discussing our content
with each other it is a pretty cool
community that is mobile ad free access
to all of the daily wire news
exclusive op-eds all of our podcasts on
our mobile app all for the low price of
one dollar best of all your dollars are
getting you the news you need without
the left leftist spin so head on over to
dailywire.com
subscribe and join today you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
alrighty so as i've been talking about
here there is a gap that's emerging
between the radical left and the
liberals and the radical left
i will say they are acting a little bit
more tepid than they were
just a few weeks ago take as an example
nicole hannah jones right
fresh off her pulitzer prize-winning
essay that was so bad four other
pulitzer prize-winning historians called
it bad
and then she won a pulitzer for it in
the in true new york times walter
drankie fashion
today she tweeted out that the 1619
project
right which which openly posited that
the actual origin of the country was not
1776 it was 1619
that every structure in america was
designed
in order to effectuate slavery and
racism i mean this is what the 6019
project openly says
now she is saying oh she's the
revisionist historian is now revising
the history of her own revisionist
history project
she says it's no longer a history and
she tweeted this out yesterday she says
it wasn't meant to be a historic project
it was a journalistic enterprise
okay sure now she says quote i've said
consistently the 1619 project is an
origin story not the origin story our
intro says explicitly what would it mean
to consider 1619 our founding
not that it is our founding uh is that
what it says because
the original language of the 1619
project which apparently is no longer
available online
but i remember it because i quoted it in
my book they said that 1619 was quote
our true founding
they stated on the 400th anniversary of
this fateful moment it is finally time
to tell our story
truthfully it was not meant as a sort of
balance or corrective to whitewashed
history
not even close it was meant as a
replacement but now you're starting to
see nicole hannah jones walk back her
own project and say oh it was just meant
to be kind of a critique it wasn't meant
to be
like an alternative history doesn't
matter that the very first page of the
16-19 project declares quote it is
finally time to tell our story
truthfully
by reframing american history treating
1619 as our nation's birth year
and placing slavery at the very center
of our national narrative
so you know she's walking it back a
little bit because it turns out that
all of the sort of radicalism of the
robin de angelos even members of the
liberal literati are beginning to say
well i'm not
so into this now trump could exploit
that right because the radical left is
going off the rails
trump could push on this particular
scene and it would be important to do
that
in order for that to happen he has to
not make boo-boos on kovad
so over the past week and a half the
president of the united states there's
one issue at the forefront of
everybody's mind that's when when the
hell can we get back to anything
remotely resembling normal right that is
the big question right now as states
consider additional lockdowns now again
what the data show
is that we are already seeing a
flattening in texas in florida
in arizona hospitalizations are going
down icu's are going down
we saw the curve the curve went up and
now the curve is coming back down and
that was happening before quote unquote
additional lockdowns
which is good which is good and frankly
i'm very curious to see what happens in
new york as new york continues to reopen
because if new york reopens and we do
not actually see a second wave we don't
see a second spike what that would
suggest
is that herd immunity doesn't kick in at
60 or 70 percent thanks to t
cell immunity it actually kicks in a lot
lower right that would be like the best
of all scenarios is that
once it runs through a community that's
it like you're basically done
that'd be you know my mouth to god's
ears we don't know that yet right
there's a lot of
scientific controversy over t-cell
resistance and t-cell immunity
but that would be great the bottom line
is what we're seeing in the sun belt for
example
is a receding of the cases and we never
saw death levels like death levels that
we saw
in new york so over the last week and a
half the president has become
or had until the last 24 hours a lot
more
i would say studied and focused on
the uh on the covet issue he just didn't
seem as wild and that was good
right he gave his typical daily presser
yesterday and he sounded pretty good
right here was president trump yesterday
encouraging people to wear masks and
social medias which has been sort of the
going
scientific advice for the last several
months
i trust all americans to do the right
thing but we strongly advise everyone
to especially especially focus
on maintaining a social distance
maintaining
rigorous hygiene avoid large gatherings
and crowded indoor bars
and wear masks when appropriate we also
strongly urge citizens to take extra
precautions to shield those
at highest risk which are in most cases
in many cases the elderly
yeah that's good that's what he should
be saying there's new evidence out today
according to the wall street journal
that says that face masks are still
fairly useful robert redfield director
of the centers for disease control and
prevention said he believes the pandemic
could be brought under control over the
next four to eight weeks
if we could get everybody to wear a mask
right now apparently it has like a very
small impact on the transmission of
covet and small numbers
but the more people wear masks the more
the curve is is really brought down
because fewer and fewer people like it
it reduces your risk of of transmitting
covaid by like 30 or 40 percent was what
i'd seen in the studies but if everybody
does that then it reduces it
by a very very large percentage there's
a newly published study suggesting that
universal use of surgical masks helps
reduce
rates of confirmed coronavirus
infections among healthcare workers at
mass general brigham
healthcare systems in massachusetts
redfield's comments are the clearest
message yet
from the cdc that they that they are
pushing the mask
wearing the cdc currently recommends the
use of cloth face coverings in public
several states have made the coverings a
requirement for most people
in wide-ranging public situations an
analysis published sunday
in the bmj a medical journal found face
coverings are now recommended or
mandated in 160 countries to reduce
coronavirus
transmission apparently according to
researchers
they say that a homemade face mask
will will radically reduce the
amount of time that that the virus is in
the air
which is which is good right and then it
reduces the amount of distance
traveled when you breathe it reduces it
from
up to apparently 100 inches if you have
an uncovered
face to uh if you have like a stitched
mask
nearly zero in other words it goes like
a little bit beyond your mouse but not
much further
than that so all of that is good right
i've never understood the perspective
that says
that we want the economy to reopen
therefore nobody wear masks if you want
the economy to
reopen you should wear a mask i mean
that is the best way you can get back to
work and i'm back at work
that's because everybody around me is
wearing a mask and when i'm not on the
camera i'm wearing a mask too
it seems to me that the easiest way for
us to get back to work is to be safe
because
you know what would happen if there's a
covered outbreak people would go home
again so what you actually want is to
reduce the transmission
so trump is saying that too also trump
is now pushing on the vaccine button
which is good
right operation warp speed is continuing
we've now moved to
phase three in certain vaccine trials
here's the president talking about this
yesterday
a groundbreaking agreement with pfizer
includes a guarantee to deliver 100
million doses
shortly after the vaccine's approval
almost
immediately with the option to purchase
an additional 500 million thereafter
not only is operation warp speed
accelerating the development of a
vaccine
we're also directing a colossal
industrial mobilization to ensure it's
rapid
delivery nothing's happened like this
since the end of world war
ii okay and he's not wrong about this
right all of this is good right there's
a more concerted trump this is what you
want to see anthony fauci
right yesterday he was out there
celebrating a stage three progression
for the vaccine he's saying this is very
good news
the virus was first put on a public
database to sequence
early on in january so to go from
not even knowing what the virus was in
early january
to a phase three trial is really record
time and i might add
it was not done compromising safety
nor was it done compromising scientific
integrity
i can't guarantee you the success of the
vaccine
because only a clinical trial will
determine that
but i can virtually guarantee you that
this has got off to a good start
and we will get this trial completed
okay so all of this
is positive news obviously now where the
democrats prefer to put their focus is
on chaos inside the administration which
is why again
if trump wants to exacerbate the scene
between radical left and
liberals which is good for the country
it's something that should happen then
he needs to not provide them a common
rallying point when he does silly things
but what the democrats would prefer to
do is rally around we hate trump and
that's what you're seeing from andrew
cuomo he says lack of a plan is called
trump
the absolute arrogance of andrew cuomo
the governor of new york suggesting
that trump's activities during covenant
19 are really the problem when his state
got
walloped actually this is chris his
brother sorry his idiot brother
who has helped push the the propaganda
here here's idiot brother chris
talking about how a lack of a plan is
called trump as opposed to his brother
who he was having on the air
and holding up giant fake nasal swabs
solid stuff here from chris cuomo help
is not coming from on high
proof there's no plan for better testing
i hear you all over this country saying
you can't get results fast enough
i know there's no plan for it to get
better
there's no plan to help us reopen
schools
and there is a reason for this in action
and it has a name
trump really your brother is the
governor of new york what's his plan
seriously what's his plan 33 000 people
died in that state
and by the way the washington post is
now saying what we should do is shut
down the entire country
for months on end in the hope that this
will bring the coronavirus infections
down to zero and then we can test and
trace everybody in a country of 330
million people ignoring the fact but we
are seeing in europe
is spikes again in a huge number of
countries that initially brought the
cases
down near zero israel had the cases down
near zero they had a spike they had to
shut down again
okay so that is not really a solution
either the bottom line is that there
aren't a lot of good solutions here
other than the stuff that we already
know
tends to reduce transmission namely the
the socially distance
and the mask wearing the idea of going
into a full-scale national the
washington post is now encouraging
people by the way like they would like
to see that if you are covet positive
that you would be forced to stay in a
hotel that the government would set up
hotels for you
and you would be forced to stay there by
law like they say this in a washington
post editorial today
they they don't explicitly say that they
want you forced into it they say we'll
set up hotels for people who want to go
yeah sure because
if i get covered what i def desperately
want to do is go to a hotel with a bunch
of other people with coved
sounds fantastic yeah but in any case
trump
you know has to be beware of making
boo-boos on kova that that
covet has really hurt his re-election
chances look at the polls
when kovid started his re-elect chances
went from basically 50-50 or 55-45
down to about 20 and which means don't
make boo-boos that make it look like you
are not on solid footing
which is why yesterday when the
president decided to retweet a breitbart
video
and and it was a video of some frontline
doctors
and they call themselves america's
frontline doctors and they're speaking
it looks like at the white house
talking about how hydroxychloric and
hydroxychloroquine
was a cure like literally a cure and
then
he was retweeting things that that said
in the video like implying that anthony
fauci was bad at his job and
and he's at fault for all of this that's
not the kind of stuff that is going to
make people feel a sense
of durability and a sense of solidity in
a time where everything feels chaotic so
trump retweeted this
the the tweet also included again
ripping on fouchu which is
like the media have been begging for
trump to go right at fouchy for
literally months for months which is bad
for the country and bad for trump
the reason that they've been pushing
this is because they want this to be a
battle between
fauci who's become sort of hero of the
resistance simply because
trump and he seem to be at odds they
want that battle they want it to look
like trump versus the science
so trump tweets this stuff out by the
way that houston
doctor she's now being ripped up and
down because
apparently she has made some claims
about alien dna
and she has made claims about demon's
sperm
and such it's not great stuff it's not
great stuff right she said
this nobody needs to get sick this virus
has a cure and she said you don't need a
mask there's a cure
so none of that is is really based in in
any sort of science
but in any case anthony fauci then went
on tv and defended himself from trump
saying
that basically he's bad at his job here
was fauci and now you got exactly what
the media wanted that faucet versus
trump battle this is not good for trump
for folks who support trump
if you think that him battling openly
with his own
his own guy right i mean fauci is the
guy he put out front in the first place
it ain't a good look he's been doing
this with every official in his
administration for a long time right
with jeff sessions
he did it with his own chief of staff
for a while like
it's a frequent thing but when it looks
like that guy stands for science and you
don't that's a bad look for you
especially because
again trump's been more focused over the
last week so set the simpsons jason's
work accident counter back to zero here
here's anthony fauci going to trump
i don't tweet i don't i don't even read
them so i i don't really want to go
there i just will continue
to do my job no matter what comes out
because i think it's very important
we're in the middle of a crisis with
regard to an epidemic a pandemic
this is what i do this is what i've been
trained for my entire professional life
and i'll continue to do it
to the charge you've been misleading the
american public
i have not been misleading the american
public under any circumstances
okay so obviously this is this sort of
conflict is bad for trump if you want
trump re-elected this is bad stuff
meanwhile twitter has decided they're
gonna ban anybody who retweets that
video right so that video comes out
i don't think that that video is
supported by the best available science
i think that the lady in the video is
making some pretty extraordinary claims
that don't seem to be based
like the idea that it's a cure does not
seem to be real reality
donald trump jr retweeted that
particular video
he tweeted this is a must watch so
different from the narrative everyone is
running with
twitter then suspended him twitter
suspended i mean and this this is insane
twitter suspended him
saying that under their policies they
violated the policy on spreading
misleading and potentially harmful
information related to covet 19.
that policy is wildly overbroad that
policy is really stupid
the reason that it's wildly overbroad is
because if you had tweeted back in march
that people should wear masks you would
have been in contradiction to the cdc
and fauci and the who the thing about
science is that until the science is
quote unquote settled you actually don't
know whether the science is settled
and the studies on hydroxychloroquine
again they're
pretty mixed right there are some that
say that it's somewhat effective there's
some that say that it is not at all
effective
the original studies were completely
debunked the ones that said that it was
going to kill you of a heart attack
those were complete those completely
fell apart they just weren't real okay
so
but the bottom line is that politically
speaking for trump
the biggest thing that he can do right
now to push for his own victory is to
force the liberals to repudiate the
radical left instead of centering
on him and his particular foibles and
set the counter back to zero because
that is not what he did today that
keep the man off of twitter for the love
of god keep the man off of twitter
for five seconds if you actually want
him re-elected all right we'll be back
here a little bit later today with two
additional hours
of content otherwise we'll see you here
tomorrow you're listening to the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
supervising producer mathis glover and
robert sterling assistant director pablo
wydowski
technical producer austin stevens
playback and media operated by nick
sheehan
associate producer katie swinerton
edited by adam syavette
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
the trump campaign does a 180 in their
attacks on biden dhs
rounds up hundreds of anarchists and joe
rogan gets video games wrong
check it out on the michael knowles show